como ya lo hemos hecho en varios vídeos
vamos a suponer que tengo un conjunto de
vectores linealmente independientes
digamos b1 b2 hasta beca y entonces b es
una base de un sub espacio vectorial de
dimensión k también voy a suponer que
cada uno de los vectores de esta base de
uno de dos hasta de acá todos pertenecen
a rn son miembros de rn en el vídeo
pasado vimos cómo definir una matriz que
llamamos de cambio de base y lo que era
era una matriz que tenía como columnas a
los vectores de mi base a b1 b2 hasta
beca esas eran las columnas de mi matriz
así que tengo acá columnas
y como cada vector de la base pertenece
a rm cada vector tiene entradas así que
tenía n filas así que la matriz de
cambio base es de n por k también vimos
en el vídeo pasado que si tenía un
vector
que estaba en rn entonces se suponía que
estaba en el sub espacio vectorial
generado por la base b entonces teníamos
que a él igual a la matriz del cambio de
base por el vector de las coordenadas de
a con respecto a la base de todo esto ya
lo habíamos visto en el vídeo pasado así
que si conozco las coordenadas de a con
respecto a la base b y le multiplicó por
la izquierda la matriz de cambio de base
entonces obtengo las coordenadas
estándar de a y al revés también podía
resolver un sistema ecuaciones y obtener
a partir de las coordenadas estándar de
a las coordenadas con respecto a la base
b
ahora en este vídeo vamos a suponer que
la matriz ce es una matriz invertible
que se posee una inversa y que significa
eso que podemos decir hacer que la
matriz c pues por un lado nos dice que
se debe ser una matriz cuadrada y eso
quiere decir que la matriz se tiene la
misma cantidad de filas que de columnas
y además nos dice que en particular sus
columnas son linealmente independientes
en realidad también sus filas pero vamos
a trabajar con las columnas como en este
caso las columnas son miembros de una
base y por definición esos tienen que
ser linealmente independientes esta
segunda condición es un poco redundante
en este caso
ahora bien si se es cuadrada entonces
como todos estos vectores todas las
columnas son hembras de rn cada tiene
que ser igual a n
así que si se descuadra da entonces k es
igual a n
o lo que es lo mismo tengo n vectores en
mi base tengo n vectores básicos si ese
es el caso entonces podríamos
preguntarnos quién es el sub espacio
generado por b
pues ahora tengo n vectores linealmente
independientes sectores linealmente
independientes
dentro de rn siempre que tenga un
conjunto de n vectores linealmente
independientes dentro de rn lo que tengo
es una base para rn puesto que cualquier
base de rm es exactamente un conjunto de
n vectores linealmente independientes
así que ve es una base para crm
ahora bien si se es invertible entonces
puedo decir que cualquier vector de rn
se puede expresar como una combinación
lineal de los vectores de la base de las
columnas de ce en el vídeo pasado nos
teníamos que asegurar que el vector a
estuviera dentro del psuv espacio
vectorial generado por los vectores de
la base pero ahora no tenemos que hacer
eso porque si se es invertible entonces
el sub espacio vectorial generado por la
base b es todo
rn de hecho al revés también es cierto
es decir si el sub espacio vectorial
generado por la base b es todo rn
entonces tengo n vectores linealmente
independientes en la base d
y además tengo una matriz cuadrada la
matriz de cambio de base es cuadrada y
sus columnas por ser miembros de la base
son linealmente independientes así que
esto es un sí sólos y si el sub espacio
bacterial generado por b es todo rm
entonces
es una matriz invertible y esto es
bastante útil porque ahora puede
reescribir esta ecuación de un modo
mucho mejor en el vídeo pasado si lo que
quería era obtener las coordenadas de a
con respecto de una cierta base b
entonces tenía que resolver un sistema
de ecuaciones y hacer un procedimiento
todo engorroso pero si mi matriz de
cambio base c es invertible entonces
para empezar todos los vectores de rn
son combinación lineal de los vectores
de mi base b así que a siempre está en
el generado de la base b pues b generar
todo rm y si multiplico esta ecuación
por la matriz inversa obtengo se inversa
por c por el vector de coordenadas de a
con respecto a la base b es igual a c
inversa por el vector a esto simplemente
es la matriz identidad así que esto lo
puede escribir simplemente como
las coordenadas con respecto a la base
ve el vector de coordenadas de a con
respecto a la base b es igual a c
inversa por nuestro vector a bien vamos
a hacer un ejemplo de esto para ver cómo
funciona vamos a usar estas fórmulas
vamos a hacer un ejemplo concreto y
vamos a trabajar
r2 voy a proponer una base es más mejor
primero empiezo con los vectores vamos a
tomarnos un b1 que va a ser el 13
y vamos a suponer que ve 23
vector 21
y les dejo ejercicio verificar que sus
vectores son linealmente independientes
y que entonces el conjunto b que
contiene a b1 y b2 es en realidad una
base para todo el espacio vectorial de
r2 muy bien entonces b es una base para
r2 sale muy bien pues con esta
información podemos escribir la matriz
de cambio de base la matriz de cambio
base es la matriz 1 2 3 1
y resulta ahora que se es invertible
puedo simplemente calcular su inversa
antes que nada el determinante s es
igual a uno por uno menos tres por dos
que es uno menos seis que es menos cinco
y ya habíamos obtenido en el pasado una
fórmula para la inversa de una matriz de
dos por dos
simplemente era seã alã menos uno es uno
entre el determinante o sea uno entre
menos 5
multiplicado por la matriz e intercambió
los elementos de la diagonal que ahora
son el mismo y les cambió el signo a los
otros dos menos dos y menos tres y ahí
tenemos la inversa algo interesante que
aprovecho para comentarles es que si
tienen una matriz con coeficientes
reales y que su determinante es distinto
de cero entonces siempre tiene una
inversa
bien pues supongamos que tengo un vector
a que está en r2 y voy a suponer que a
digamos es el vector 72 entonces quiere
encontrar cuáles son las coordenadas de
a con respecto de la base p
así que con respecto a la base de quién
es pues
ahora estoy en esta situación y puedo
aplicar la fórmula conozco quién es
y tengo mi motriz inversa así que se
multiplicó se inversa por el vector y
obtengo las coordenadas ok déjenme lo
noto por aquí las coordenadas de a con
respecto a la base b es igual a la
matriz de s inversa multiplicada por el
vector a en las coordenadas estándar así
que las coordenadas de al respecto a la
base b es igual a la inversa que es
menos un quinto por la matriz 1 - 3 - 21
multiplicado por el vector
qué es el 72 ya cuánto es igual esto
pues es menos un quinto multiplicado por
el vector que nos da el producto de
matrices 1 por 7 más menos 2 por 27
menos 4 que es 3 y luego menos 3 por 7
que es menos 21 más 1 por 2
es menos 21 por dos es 1919
así que las coordenadas de a con
respecto a la base b
las coordenadas con respecto a la base b
son y sólo tengo que multiplicar el
menos un quinto por el vector menos tres
quintos y luego 19 puntos positivos así
que esas son las coordenadas de mi
vector con respecto a la base b bien
pues vamos a verificar esto vamos a
checar que lo que acabamos de hacer si
funciona las coordenadas con respecto a
la base me dicen los coeficientes de la
combinación lineal que me da el vector
así que esto sería menos tres quintos
por mi primer vector de mi base que
sería el b 11 13 + 19 quintos por el
segundo vector de la base 2 1
esto me debería dar el vector a ahora
tienes esto
pues esto es menos tres quintos por uno
y luego menos tres quintos por tres
menos nueve quintos
más y ahora multiplico el otro vector es
el 19 quintos por 2 que sería el 38
quintos
y 19 por una vez 10 en el quinto
si son nuestros dos vectores que obtengo
obtengo menos tres quintos más treinta y
ocho quintos que es 35 quintos 35 entre
5 y 7 y luego menos 9 quintos más 19
quintos es
diez quintos o sea dos así que de nuevo
obtuve el vector
y el lector definitivamente tiene
coordenadas con respecto a la base de
simplemente es menos tres quintos del
primer vector de uno más 19 puntos del
segundo vector de 2
ahora qué pasó si quiero hacer lo
contrario supongamos que digo qué
el vector w tiene coordenadas con
respecto a la base ve digamos algo
simple 1 1
11 entonces quién es el vector w en
términos de la base estándar quiénes son
sus coordenadas estándar pues ahora
simplemente tengo que multiplicar al
vector de coordenadas por la matriz de
cambio de base y lo tengo que
multiplicar por la izquierda eso es
importante así que la matriz de cambio
base es la
13 21
las coordenadas de w con respecto a b 11
y esto nos da uno por uno más dos por
uno es tres y luego tres por uno más uno
por uno
+ 1 es 4 así que w es simplemente el
vector 34 así que si nuestra matriz de
cambio de bases invertible que como
vimos es equivalente a que nuestra base
genere a todo rm entonces podemos pasar
rápidamente entre las coordenadas
estándar
y las coordenadas con respecto a una
base y viceversa entonces estas son
coordenadas con respecto a una base y
estas son sus coordenadas estándar
estas son las coordenadas de un vector
respecto a la base y estas son sus
coordenadas estándar y lo hacemos
utilizando esta fórmula en la que
podemos decir abre las coordenadas con
respecto a la base son simplemente la
matriz inversa el cambio de base por el
vector a o diciendo que el vector
respecto a la base estándar es igual a
la matriz de cambio coordenadas por el
vector de coordenadas con respecto a la
base